the final CS go major is set to kick off
on Monday and will Mark a two-week
send-off for the game in preparation of
Counter-Strike 2. 11 years culminating
in one final tournament and honestly
anyone can take home this Monumental
trophy
all right everyone before we get into
the video I just wanted to give a quick
shout out to our partners over at
Qualcomm Technologies and the Snapdragon
Elite Gaming Team they've been helping
us explore mobile Esports and the
mind-blowing technology that's the
driving force behind it so if you want
to learn more about that make sure you
check out our episode of cracked on the
explosive rise of mobile Esports using
the link below and stay tuned for more
mobile Esports content as we head to the
Snapdragon Pro Series mobile Masters in
Tokyo okay so before we get into the
final goddamn CS go major that's just a
few days away I need to make sure that
everyone is properly hyped sure it may
seem like Counter-Strike 2 is basically
just the same game and updated and yes
in some ways it definitely is but you
have to think about the context coming
into this major and what's at stake for
a lot of these players CS go Majors have
always been the standard for what
separates a good player from a great one
winning just one cements you in the
history of the game forever and you
can't really say that about any other
tournament King's crowned curses formed
dynasties solidified majors are
responsible for heartbreak Euphoria and
have made its winners household names
around the world majors are mythological
by definition and this will be every
player's last chance to not be part of
the last CS go manager you're missing
out on being part of History by default
because anyone that's there is part of
History you know it's part of the last
major in CS go as we know it I mean if
you still somehow don't understand the
gravity of it all just look at the tears
that were shed during qualifiers for so
many of these players this was their
last opportunity to make their Mark sure
it's entirely possible that CS2 will be
even more popular as an esport but
there's also a chance that it won't be
and not a single player analyst or fan
knows what the landscape is going to
look like by the end of the year players
will retire teams will leave the game
entirely and new ones will enter so as
much as this is going to be a fresh
start it will also Mark the end of an
era with that said I do think that blast
the teams in attendance and the City of
Paris itself is going to give us one
hell of a send-off and honestly we gotta
talk about it because this has the
potential to be the most unpredictable
major in history and it hasn't even
started yet and we've already seen a ton
of upsets C9 is out astralis is out hell
even the defending Champions missed the
cut and I think bit by bit his number is
off the Flames will tickle him and a
jump Peak as well should give it up jdc
sees it all and just like that Mouse
continue their dream here but they
eliminate vertice Pro from the
possibility of making their way towards
Paris with the headlines of the changes
with Norbit brought in at last minute
they bomb out of the EU rmra
we had a lot of questions coming into
this one I think we have even more now
and no one knows what is going on but
not the VP that we were expecting a
shadow of their former selves as they
get knocked out instead we have teams
like bad news Eagles and into the breach
who cleared it all the way to the legend
stage while phases in the lowest seed
now although the qualifiers did cause a
lot of question marks we still have our
favorites G2 Navi heroic vitality and
yes even phase are all the strongest
teams right now and probably have the
best chance at securing a dub and each
of these teams come with their own
incredible storylines so let's talk
about them vitality and heroic are
currently the biggest Front Runners
right now just because they've had the
most success as of late heroic has
definitely been the most consistent team
in the last while and with coming so
close at both Rio and katowice it feels
like a massive win is just within Arm's
Reach and heroic winning the last ever
CS go major would definitely be
something not even mentioning the entire
coaching bug Scandal Kaden is probably
the most controversial CS GoPro over the
last few years that being said love him
or hate them you can't deny the journey
this guy has gone through and an all
Danish roster winning the last ever CS
go major would further solidify them as
the most dominant region what about
Vitality well they are looking just as
strong as anyone else right now and they
are coming off the most recent win where
they just beat heroic so if I were a
betting man I'd probably put my money on
Vitality I mean just look at the
storylines Dupree is the only player in
CS go history to attend every single
major all 19. he's already won more than
any other player but securing the final
CS go major that's goat's status and
there is of course zywoo the literal
antithesis to cadian's controversy
seeing him finally get a win that's
worthy of his skill level would be a
great way to cap off CS go Dimitri mayor
of Maynard written that line next up we
have G2 and I think the story lines
speak for themselves there can Nico do
it after all the chances after all the
Heartbreak can he finally win his major
or will it be simple and Navi well the
most individually talented player in the
history of the game be Crown King one
last time how about FaZe they have
proved time and time again that they
have that X Factor but more than any
other team those boys have quite the
journey ahead of him but when it comes
to each of these three juggernauts it's
all about consistency despite their
Firepower and skill they all lack
stability and that stability is going to
be key because although these five teams
have dominated most of the conversations
over the past few weeks as I've said
it's truly anyone's tournament ever
since the real major and maybe even
before that the skill gap between teams
has shrunk significantly and although
certain teams have better fundamentals
than others upsets have become
increasingly more common and when it
comes to teams like liquid Furia ants
and other so-called middle of the pack
teams I think sponge said it best there
are no more excuses Naf elage and
yakinda you telling me you don't think
like if those three players are on form
OC is having it having a good time even
Nitro has had some like crazy impact
rounds recently I know it needs to be to
the higher level but it can get there
like I don't know why we would assume
that it can't get there apparently
according to my little timeline as well
they started boot camping on the 22nd of
April so it seems like they're gonna
haven't there shouldn't be an excuse for
the major of a team going we didn't get
enough practice against European
Counter-Strike like that doesn't exist
anymore because we're in this period of
Counter-Strike where we can't even
establish like we can establish who the
top pack is but like in terms like who
the top dog is page or TV rankings as of
yes uh two days ago right puts heroic up
there but it doesn't it doesn't mean as
much as it did previously like I can't
remember a major that we've gone into
where we have such an open feel but
that's enough for me I want to hear from
you guys what are your favorite
storylines heading into this tournament
and who do you want to see when the last
ever CS go major let me know in the
comments and as always stay safe have
fun I'll see you on the next one
yeah imagine North America like liquid
or like complexity somehow win the final
major and then CS2 just dies like just
for some reason no one plays it you're
down like five nothing at recess and
it's like all right last goal wins
that'd be the most North American thing
ever too last major wins were the best
actually now